you
all right this is the wholock tournament
a 3-2 bullets form at 50 minutes of
three two chests all right so let's see
how many games we could get in here this
is certainly different ooh I'm noticing
that I'm I'm able to move the pieces
quicker for some reason it seems like
they're snapping out faster from when I
played last in the tournament so that's
nice let's get my bishop here
stop Bishop f5 let's back up so there
won't be any time burner stuff I'll play
this see if they damage my structure I
didn't come in my King to the Kings side
yet so if they give me the G file maybe
I play against their king additionally
maybe I drop my knight in here
yeah maybe regardless like if they
defend that square I would still go
Queen side so they just gave up what
they give up their LightSquared bishop
let's put the rook right here
immediately occupy that half open file
queenside castle i don't know could I
get away with keeping the King in the
center now let's get these moves in King
V one rook c1 maybe play against this
pawn if b4 probably Knight a four this
is a weak square they might try to jump
into c4 that can be a bit disruptive
okay let's defend here they were
threatening you kick my knight I can
consider also Queen a4
I think I like this though actually
getting a night right here wouldn't that
be absolutely deadly Queen a4 where
would the Queen go Queen a4 Queen b6 a
queen a4 night Queen a4 and Queen c7
then I have to move my knight he can't
go to see can't go to a4 hmm now let's
go for this if they go for Queen trade I
think it just favored me if they go for
Queen trade because they have the worst
structure Wow
was not expecting that they might end up
not being able to get rid of their pawn
actually even if they do get rid of
their pawn I'll have a target in that of
the d5 pawn so this shouldn't be an
issue against their king mmm and
consider that I think I should take the
knight oh no no no no we go here on
Bishop takes Knight I take here just
just flat out winning because I have
those uh discovered check ideas rook
takes pawn uh-huh so now what should I
do
I feel like I just want to stop this a
pawn from advancing Knight a6 rook c1
and slowly build up let me do that this
is a fine square for the knight
threatening I'm not threatening anything
that's this is defend oh maybe I am
threatening something excuse me
threatening to take the bishop and then
take here there's no trick b8 slow
improving moves are this rook c1 this
pawn is a good one and it kills the
night I have good control over this
position this is maybe an idea it's one
piece
okay should I go straight in for this
now let's disrupt the ruck position
working with the two bishops they
usually function very well on adjacent
diagonals it's going for that and now
should I just cash out take here and
then take on b4 yeah let's do something
quick and grab a pond there's no push
controlling c8 that has to be pretty
awkward rook here how are they defending
this guy Knight C for it to be a bit
careful of these checks and then getting
here let's put pressure okay I want to
stop knight here hmm I'm just going to
take a moment out to secure this square
I guess on rook b8 I have to go here you
know a3 a5 there's night a3 so I'm
looking at this be a bit careful because
I'll be opposite there bishop with my
king in the corner maybe this night a3
then here now he could return to c4 I
want to get rid of their night I'm going
to make that difficult hmm let's start
with this though and what next let's go
here I still need to get rid of their
Knight to b3 pretty even
the clock ten-second advantage but it's
not so much I'm up upon but kind of
tough maybe I should have captured maybe
I should not have captured on that
square b3 hmm
maybe I maybe I'm going to invest the
exchange and then play against C at that
pond I think I have good control this
night on d3 is pretty strong so I have
two two ponds for the exchange my bishop
is a loose piece rook b5 don't want to
do this I want to maintain the structure
yeah I want to maintain the structure
now this pond is pinned
let's pinpoint c6 I want to get my king
over here like yesterday
King bee one King see - yeah let's do it
if they're F pawn is free I think I want
to play here just so I can retreat on f5
I have very good control I could even
consider b4 maybe King C - B for King b3
maybe I can put some pressure on them
with the clock let's start with that for
Oh didn't even consider that all right I
need to have a little bit of a role
reversal hmm what's wrong with
like this move huh that's like a passing
move night right here night right here
and then the pond Falls okay I have
enough coverage though on this square
I'll push with this one and now I could
just start rolling yeah this is a
tsunami of ponds let's keep control over
the dark squares this is a super
defender and now we could even question
their king position have my pawns
controlled arc to give a check oh it's
close to mate isn't it
I don't know bishop here if the King
goes there let's keep going my knight is
really good less than 10 let's keep
going my bishop is killing both of their
rooks just to improve my King position a
little bit go here Knight f4 is close to
mate that's mate who that game took
forever
we're already 40 there's only 40 minutes
left okay yeah that's why I want to do a
longer time control that one turned very
positional I must have had something
better you know instead of taking on f6
what's he resigned who's in first a
quick resigner oh I got fire and
everything
there's 58 players all right cool bunch
here from this created wholock
tournament let's see how I get paired up
with next who's playing right now Anton
cubed vs. tsunami of ponds tsunami of
ponds is in the tournament it'll just
cut away right if my game starts when
I'm viewing the tournament just make
sure I'm still in there Captain Obvious
is playing didn't he just finish
maybe I'm getting paired up with sheppy
13 and it's taking a little bit for me
to get paired there we go okay let's try
you for what I do in that last game I
play Knight f3 yeah all right efore it
is let's try Bishop b5 positional
positional miss and we're going to baby
step it Queen e2 yeah let's go Queenie -
maybe this idea hmm let me just stop
that Knight move we're going to do this
first I'm taking these steps because I
don't want the d4 move to be met with d5
I want to secure B form and I'm looking
to get this movin next and I got it in
so I have this ideal pawn center but he
still needs to play these squares are
under control of Knight a5 I could just
kick them and play Bishop b2 so can I
control this Knight slow improving move
as h3 just getting a flight Square in
there
huh I wonder if some idea with Rick be
one and then my night is free to move
because I think as soon as he moves
there's going to be a quick 95 to c4 so
I want to kind of stop that may be
moving the rook and then pivoting coming
over here could I look forward to an
attack against the King I don't know
what's something more I could look into
well now that I have this ideal pawn
center I should be considering some pawn
push with tempo at some stage actually I
want to be a bit careful as soon as I
move this Knight d5 there may even be a
pawn sack idea let's get my rook here
secure this pawn yeah there might be
this idea takes and then playing against
this square you know positional
sacrifice to to make use of the d5
square here here there a knight exchange
I went upon this Bishop wasn't here
there'd be a 97 to d5 maneuver I have
this reposition out okay
so night here d5 push Knight g3 forces
an exchange of knights
I guess now they're lining up Knight a5
into c4 since the Queen and rook are
there so maybe I should consider B for
right now I think that that's fine yeah
no there isn't a sacrifice working here
Knight takes Queen here hitting these
two could be met with Knight b3 either
Knight to b3 and it defends the rook
okay I think that my bishop knows his
place so let's get there and soon we're
going to be opposite their queen so
she's going to have to find a new home
meanwhile this might be an idea as well
looking to damage the Kings side we'll
see
now this seems too sensible not to play
like right away here I can sneak in
another quick move like h3 super
threatening right I could dislodge this
Knight okay they're going in for this
now yeah so maybe I should do what hmm
well we're gonna focus on this square I
think they're going to get into c4
though huh oh let me I don't want to
allow that night to get there so easily
let's take some care over these light
squares that's where I'm very weakened
they have better harmony between their
pawn structure and Bishop I'm playing
with the space advantage but can I
really put this guy to use maybe now
that I don't have a knight on f4 this is
possible Knight c5 is my DeWitt's knight
b3 I just want to cover this square and
I'll probably go in for that night a4
shouldn't be so much for bother just
backup
hmm what's the story there
well let's jump right in I'd like to
have my bishop extended some oh they
just dropped their Knight they missed
that whoops see how they resigned right
yeah they resigned back determined yep
and they had the old oh I didn't see
that backward move there I was a sudden
end that was the big battle that was
going on they had a good harmony as
mentioned with their pawn structure and
remaining Bishop I had a space advantage
a lot of the attention we saw was a on
that C file and those pivot squares the
squares where the wechat upon
controlling those C file squares all
right we got black for the first time
here still 33 minutes left in this one
11 8 7 is where we are at let's try an
Enzo
Knight c3 Knight f3 all right names Oh
Indian it is classical line Queen C to
be trying to employ a dark square
strategy here cannot rely upon my dark
square Bishop I'm prepared to give him
up if questioned be taking the night out
be looking to have the harmony between
my structure and the light square bishop
if he's no longer around
so let's first give him let's ask him a
question okay um
actually I had a look at this not too
long ago at the computer and that's a
mistake because of this move and I could
move further kick the knight and then
take here and that is a super important
pawn so maybe they consider a sacrifice
but still I have this idea in mind so
let's see I could even consider maybe if
Knight takes pawn takes Bishop takes
taking here and if Queen takes Knight e4
the fork Bishop takes Queen Knight takes
Queen Bishop takes pawn and I just run
away
- maybe e4 I mean I could be challenged
then I could a counter attack I don't
think it would go that far but I know
there in the think tank they must be
considering this if they go here it's a
clear pawn g4 here so maybe this is the
best idea I don't know if I can manage
to get out of this pin there's that's
going to be the big test for me can I
find a convenient way to get out of this
potential pin against my knight
okay I was ready to do this first
careful now
also he could wrap around to f5 Knight
h4 Knight takes pawn here no excuse me
Knight age for the Queen has to react
after this and then who okay so things
are certainly getting pretty sharp but
is that really a good idea hmm
interesting pawn takes pawn takes Knight
takes Queen efore check I could play
Knight here though and then I'm still on
both nights I think that this is correct
to take here because I mean my bishop is
now brought to life and I think that
this is fine Knight takes here hang on
my rook is hanging hmm I don't think
that that could be taken advantage of
though I have everything defended he
defends here the knight is pinned
queenie for this Knight here I want to
keep pressure on this night I have a
minute advantage they still have to
address a threat against their night at
some point so Queen here while
aggressive looking it's releasing some
defense of c3 this was my idea I have
stuff all this stuff is defended good
coordination here he's the only one
that's loose so Queen d4 maybe I'm
probably just sidestep maybe there's
even lateral movement it's pretty sure
it's good that I have some time here
also a potential developing move with
tempo multiple threats here to win the
rook okay they just Castle I could take
here and then take here or take here
actually because I'm on the Queen Queen
takes bishop there's this I don't take
the rook in pawn takes I could go here
with check and then take their night so
I'm going to be up at peace actually I
could do better let's get the Queen now
they're down on time but that was busted
there have the Queen there and a pin 16
13 12 9 8 less than a half hour left
spinal tap is not playing so I'm maybe
going to get paired up with him because
Anton cubed is playing right here there
we go alright let's go with Knight f3
and d4 and oh I don't know how about we
go at c4 I'm going to take on c4 let's
go with III I play this in the Simon
not too long ago a few days back against
the Prince as white
you
how about we go at night here yeah let's
do that
I'm preparing to meet v5 with b3 hmm
also on that move down I have night here
yeah let me challenge that pickup now
let's see on Bishop g4 Queen b3 b5 I
take and then challenge the bishop with
h3 it could be a little bit
uncomfortable for me to get my bishop
out if my queen is on beat 3 it's you
know seeing the bishop come on this
diagonal is a bit far-fetched okay can I
have that so I'm expecting b5 although
Queen c7 may be not a bad idea but maybe
on Queen c7 okay that's a little bit
awkward but I think that's still fine
okay let's hunt down there light square
bishop this is what I have to play for
and now one moment to pause here
should I take right now also another
question is should I take on this square
first before II 6 I don't want that
capture to happen hmm
let's let's
this tension I don't see a clear
positive connected with capturing I
still don't think that I should capture
the bishop just yet
what about c5 that's too early hmm just
castle it's pretty simple
yeah let's castle want to make sure that
this Bishop doesn't escape and having
said that maybe Bishop here is a sneaky
idea if I capture pawn takes and then
he's kind of stranded not sure how long
I could delay this capture I'd like to
see black first castle and then I'll
take that way I don't have to worry
about this being a half-open file for
the rook we're going to see I could
consider some if I have the time I'd
like to clamp down with c5 and f4
controlling both pawn breaks by black
I'd really like to see that happen it
just helps my development Bishop is free
the knight has new prospects they give
up their center point I don't see this
happening but maybe Knight here okay is
now the time
take the bishop and then maybe play f4
or how about take the bishop and then
play here actually what's wrong with
that it seems like a good way forward
hmm maybe a bit too quick about g5 hmm
or none of the above let's go hear these
sacrifices shouldn't be working with the
Queen coming out because I can move the
rook and King f1 this will be a super
defender mmm they're stopping that but
he is also weakened so I want to try and
pinpoint here and also I'm playing with
the two bishops so let's look to open up
this position now their King is in the
center I have this square cover of my
queen I'll so I'm only realizing that
now so a bit lucky right there I'd like
to break down their light squares some
more if I move my F pawn when my King is
vulnerable on this dog and I'll the rook
is very awkward now that the position is
opened up mm-hmm maybe I have something
sneaky in mind with can I push right now
mmm
I don't know let's let's go here for
starters well I don't have much time 19
seconds I was considering this but under
Queen here there's Bishop f4 hmm Queen
there and I know I got to make a fast
move I think just drop my Bishop back
are they gonna Castle probably rook a8
okay no that's still not working now
they're going to move the rook for sure
let's get here less than 10 seconds
let's put pressure on there pawn he
might be pawn free I think I wanted yeah
gotta stop Knight g6 I think I want my
King on g2 now yeah a knight on g6 see I
need to stop that otherwise he's getting
to one of these two hmm put some
pressure on the bishop also going into a
pin here even on the clock got to take
him out
am I not winning upon here though so I
put that and look upon that move hmm I
didn't see that okay let's go here maybe
still look to attack their King or not
mmm they could take on d4 they got c6
hmm okay when I try to hold this to a
draw they're going to hunt that pawn
down three verses to see if I could get
one exchange in another stopping that so
let's see if they could use some good
technique here to beat me and try and
keep pressure on their f7 pawn you know
let's just state pressure keep pressure
on that guy mmm step up with the King
yeah let's go up I'm a little bit
fearful about five I want to stop that
push maybe it's best here to secure my
king position now yeah I think this is
the right idea
oh that's where the king is going okay
King up and I got mate okay Jay King h5
King h8 I want to exchange my H pawn off
okay want that f-pawn got to get in a
good position here to question their
king position I'm going to keep their
king cut off the rook has to come over
to like e seven in the meantime I could
improve my King position let's do that
and hmm let's go here and then King here
check I want to get my King right here
let's give this check the rook is going
to block but I don't have time to
calculate the King upon ending I think I
was able to do that hmm all right I want
to get I want to question their King
position I think I should be able to
continually do that
sneaky hangover kind of box out there
King and get within checking distance
again think really soon let's come over
here yeah I just think I keep my King
here King comes over here okay there we
go so the drawing way maybe they're
offering a draw soon might have a
repetition I guess we're going
repetition town that's going to do it
okay yep they were of course those side
pressing in that game right there why
did it take twenty minutes
I didn't see that Queen see to move that
was a nice double attack I was like oh
they just dropped enough pawn but in the
end they get it back hitting both c4 and
a2 now let's still run with c4 high
Knight c3 now let's go at Queen b3 and
have this line starting with Queen b6
Queen b6 c5 Queen trade I'm going to
look to play on the a file mm-hmm
that isn't a good move I don't think
because I just pushed this was a
desirable move anyhow so this is an
instance of them provoking a move that I
just wanted to play and let's give my
bishop here first and then III this
isn't stopping b5 I can still get this
in due to the pin
maybe night here if they don't play
night there I could consider preserving
my bishop and let's actually do that I
want to make sure I keep my dark square
bishop around and let's just get this in
and then after they Castle and the rook
is defended now this is a threat so I
want to make sure I undid capture and
develop so I have exactly what I would
want here regarding my bishop in pawn
structure the bishop is outside of my
pawn chain should the B file open up
it's nice that I have control over b8
would make life difficult for black to
contest the C file I could take that
night and see a good reason to do that
though strop back I don't know if I want
a castle this might be a fine home for
my King King D to be form I'm going to
go with my instinct King D - it is
shouldn't be too fearful of that just
take him out knight on e4 I'm pretty
sure this is where my king belongs rook
here I can't go to b1 just like they
can't go to b8 let's get there let me
keep some pressure on them with the
clock maybe I should be a little bit
quicker to jump in here maybe I was too
fast to play rook c1 maybe this was a
better idea doubling on the a file with
the b5 break okay where's that night
going well there's no disconnect between
the rook so I could get this move in
this rook is back to being pinned knight
c6 was the idea so this should be just
winning now for me this is a move or I
could even look to target a5 but I don't
think there's any rush let's start with
this looking to crush their King side
structure
chip has to move he goes here then that
renews back rank stuff so I could pick
up the bishop pair should I do that I
like that idea like a pinpoint that pawn
b6 is an idea as well are they lining
this up maybe let's not a bother here I
just backup my bishop
let's pinpoint let's secure efore let's
strike it this square and let's come all
the way back okay
can I do something really simple like
double up on the a file or should I
consider first b6 p6 and then double up
on the a file b6 opens up this square
for my pieces yeah I like this idea a
knight getting in here that's got to be
oh yeah this is this has to be right a
knight right here these two jumping
points call it three jumping points
maybe even ideas connected with
exchanging off dark square Bishop sand a
knight on d6 which would be enormous
eight different possibilities from that
point these are the uses the ideal
squares for that night these 16 maximum
number of moves and then here and a
return there on e5 I'm just never taking
I want to keep this nice pawn chain
complemented well with this guy okay
he's not a bother
feels like they need to go for a pee
sack here I guess they're just
anticipating you know what you know what
blacks best try is they're going to have
to go with the pee sack they're going to
have to go with chop chop chop and then
three pawns for the piece so let me
actually negate that one idea they have
I don't want to allow this pee sock idea
because they may in fact be able to hunt
down a third pawn to at least directly
but then I'd have to be defending b6 so
let's just rule this out all together
maybe even have Bishop b5 as an idea it
could also look at this and then a push
with push interesting move they're
preparing e5 can I not just get away
right now it's pushing let's prep this
preparing c6 and just pushing right
through c6 it would have to be first
rook takes is otherwise be seven hits
this opens up this square for my bishop
that definitely feels right because the
knight is now also in a pin King has to
come over and now I could even step my
king up to defend this pawn playing with
ten seconds okay they're putting up some
good resistance here hmm should I just
push through here with c6 let's go for
it and then push again I think I can do
this
also I could have taken in the taken
here this is still going to work though
I have some discovery to check against
their king yeah so I could take here
take here and now next I'm looking to
push and take the rook if their bishop
moves ok so now they're going to go in
for this get the beep on or not okay but
this pawn is living though late on c5
can't stop that at d7 controlled ok
they're just playing it out some now
let's just secure my king position King
d3 ok they resigned maybe one more game
could get in I'm at 16 um what just Oh
for a second I thought there was some
issue with the score here I was like why
do I not have fire it's because I drew
that last that last game okay so one
more game this will most likely be the
last one Captain Obvious isn't at first
there with 32 that's a lot of games
alright let's try another one here okay
so a BOGO Indian now or maybe let's go
for this Queen's Indian okay I covered
many games well a few games at least
from the candidates tournament with it
where black was playing this
all right let's see if I could
inconvenience white a little bit Bishop
d2 if Knight c3 I think I could take all
right so now let's just be sneaky let's
just drop back and now let's return here
to b7 yeah
and this queen is a little bit misplaced
I believe I play this move right now
should I play d5 at this moment bishop
eform hmm let me think for a moment if I
counsel is d5 going to be played hmm I
don't think that that's a so much of a
bother
I could even consider c6 in that case
hmm all right let's go with d5 hmm
okay what about knight c6 feel like I've
already misplaced misplayed this
position hmm you know something's gone
wrong let's just reinforce d5 they may
end up playing with this space advantage
efore and then e5 I'm going to be
challenging this Knight so on e4 Knight
here Knight takes Queen takes e5 my head
so they'll have some space potentially
let's see 97 takes takes takes I could
do it in between takes and then take
here let's get that in so this was one
of the things Knight takes Queen takes
and they could do this they have some
space but we have three minor pieces not
a full four versus four and he's kind of
stranded if he goes over here so I think
I have to do this here out over here
it's a little bit surprising to see that
it's pretty early capture so I take like
this I don't want to give this on a
possibility to move hmm
okay well thinking about f5 yeah I don't
think I could allow f5 to hit pawn takes
I'm taking with the knight I want to try
and take advantage of this square this
is a gap in their position under minute
3:20 left in the tournament to take or
not so now we're
every moment of course these on percent
on Poisson ideas alright night takes
they might pinpoint this guy yep
well I think I need to focus on this
yeah I got to get rid of this night and
post up on e4 otherwise this pressure is
too much
Bishop h3 I think I need to defend that
move huh take that pawn though right I
guess the Queen is going to come
sweeping in I imagine we're soon going
to have an opposite color Bishop type
position less than 40 okay clean
exchange it is got to take out this
Knight and then jump in here 94 rook
exchange you may both end up with a
passed pawn we'll see feels kind of Josh
but white is the side here playing for
something with the bishop pair can they
work around my knight okay interesting
takes rook let's start with that Mike
takes bishop and then rook here hmm I
don't know how I feel about that let's
try for this rook here I guess no less
than a minute in the tournament I have
10 seconds I'm going to struggle now I
can't take because then there's a c4
idea bishop check I should have
considered that they're going to give a
check to me though Bishop h3 Bishop b4
hmm all right I'm going to just try and
hold on here bishop on c4 I need to get
out of this pin and I wanted to stop a
c4 move let's stay here Bishop there
I've got to control these squares from
there King this should be a draw I'll
push let's just kick their King away
yeah this this should be fine to hold
give my pawns on dark over here
tournament's over so let's see how this
one finishes could they really try for
something there's only one weakness so
we're going to have this repetition you
know there really wasn't anything the
big thing was to keep the bishops on
board or not I think you have to go for
that to try for a win it's my guess or
right here keep the rook on the board
and I know this is tight game I needed
to act fast there with that e4 square ok
this tournament is officially over final
standings Captain Obvious with
perfect streak there 36 points 29 24 24
17 and hikes 2 3 I only had six games in
down here at 1671 total players all
righty
2 3 4 5 6 7 8
all right to the 71 of you that took
part in this good games oh that was fun
you